do you believe  that in this calendar year of 2022  uh  biden will leave office  i you know that'd be subjective i pray  for that  [Laughter]  now listen i'm praying against it so the  prayer cancels out and i guess we'll  have to go with the courts or something  like that  this is the least optimistic that pillow  has been and even in his interview with  me he was insisting it's all going to  happen it's all going to happen it's all  going to happen so a deflated mic pillow  here is mike pillow also uh this just a  couple days ago  saying his new thing is trying to get  different voting locales  to change the voting machines that they  use on his recommendations like dude you  make pillows not voting machines oh  we're doing this and what we're doing we  have teams all these grass roots they  will be approaching by the way i love is  that a minnesota accent grassroots that  is just i am i think i'm gonna adopt  that i like that